and the Oscar goes to Jennifer Connelly
a beautiful
M by some beautiful twist of fate I've
landed in this vocation that demands
that I feel and helps that helps me to
learn and no film has moved or taught me
more than a beautiful mind thank you to
all of our magnificent cast and crew for
their invaluable collaboration and most
especially to Ron Howard and to Russell
Crow thanks to all the artists who have
inspired me and the list is too long
thanks to my dearest ones who give me
love and support Risa shyro Carrie Ross
my family and
friends I believe in love that there is
nothing more important Alicia Nash is a
true champion of love and so thank you
to her for her example my son Kai is for
me the greatest messenger and so thank
you to him for all of our days thank you
very much